carpal tunnel syndrome occurs when
swelling within a tightly enclosed area
of the wrist known as the carpal tunnel
puts pressure on the median nerve that
passes through it over time this can
cause progressive numbness tingling and
weakness where the median nerve sends
its branches to the palm and fingers of
the affected hand carpal tunnel syndrome
tends to strike people with jobs that
require them to perform the exact same
wrist stressing motions over and over it
may also be due to wrist injuries
rheumatoid arthritis
or hormonal or metabolic changes
a tough band of tissue called the
transverse carpal ligament stretches
across the wrist forming the roof of the
carpal tunnel a carpal tunnel release is
a surgical procedure in which this band
is cut releasing pressure on the nerve
and relieving the symptoms of carpal
tunnel syndrome
when you arrive at the hospital for the
surgery an intravenous line will be
started and you may be offered a
medication to help you relax
carpal tunnel release can be performed
under general anesthesia which will put
you to sleep for the duration of the
operation a regional nerve block which
keeps you numb from the shoulder down or
local anesthesia which keeps your wrist
area numb
an uncomplicated carpal tunnel release
usually takes between 30 and 90 minutes
there are two ways to perform the
surgery in the traditional open
procedure your surgeon will begin by
making a single incision in your palm
and wrist
he or she will then dissect through the
underlying tissues to reach the
transverse carpal ligament and cut it
thus creating more room for the median
nerve
a new or minimally invasive technique
requires only two tiny keyhole incisions
or puncture wounds rather than a single
relatively large incision it is designed
to produce a shorter and less painful
recovery period the procedure begins
when your surgeon uses sharp instruments
called trocars to make two small
openings or ports in your wrist and the
palm of your hand your surgeon will then
insert a fiber optic device into the
wrist port images from its camera are
magnified and projected onto a video
monitor in the operating room using
instruments passed through the other
port your surgeon will cut the
transverse carpal ligament
at the conclusion of either procedure
the wounds are closed with sutures
after the surgery your wrist and forearm
will be put into a splint and you will
be taken to the post-surgical recovery
area for monitoring you will be given
pain medication as needed since a carpal
tunnel release is an outpatient
procedure most patients are released
within a few hours you will need to
arrange for a family member or friend to
give you a ride home